all: OM.
- MY GOD, THIS IS GAY.
- HELLO, TRAVELERS.
I'M ASTRAL, YOUR NEW INSTRUCTOR.
- [chuckles]
HEY, BUDDY, I'D LIKE
TO POSITION MYSELF IN HER LOTUS,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
- OKAY, EVERYONE,
CLOSE YOUR EYES,
INHALE A LONG, DEEP BREATH,
AND IMAGINE A CALM,
SERENE SCENE.
♪
- OH!
- UP YOURS, CRACKER!
[all complaining at once]
- NOOO!
- WOODY, CALM DOWN.
HERE, PET ME.
I'M KIDDING.
ATTACK!
[all grunting]
- I AM GONNA CHOKE THE LIFE
OUTTA ALL OF YOU'S!
CAN'T BITCH
IF YOU CAN'T BREATHE!
- [groans]
- OOPSIE.
- WOODY,
I HAVE NEVER SEEN
SUCH A DISPLAY OF RAW PASSION.
I SUGGEST
A PRIVATE SESSION.
I CAN HELP YOU CHANNEL
THAT RAGE AND FIND INNER PEACE.
- OKAY,
IF IT'LL HELP ME RELAX.
- OH, MY GOD!
WHAT HAPPENED HERE?
- IT WAS A BLACK GUY.
I THINK HE HAD A JET PACK.